MOMENT.
FIRST I WANT TO GET YOU SOME OF
THE OTHER INTERNATIONAL STORIES
THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING HERE.
AND IN UKRAINE FIRE AND SIRENS
CONSUMED THE CAPITOL'S SKY
OVERNIGHT.
DEBRIS RAINED DOWN DURING A
MASSIVE ATTACK ON KYIV OF A
MAGNITUDE NOT SEEN IN MONTHS.
THAT'S FROM A CITY MILITARY
OFFICIAL WHO SAYS TWO PEOPLE
WERE KILLED AFTER SEVERAL GROUPS
OF DRONES APPROACHED FROM
MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS.
MEANTIME RUSSIA WAS ALSO HIT.
IT SAW THE BIGGEST DRONE ATTACK
ON ITS TERRITORY SINCE ITS FULL
SCALE INVASION OF UKRAINE BEGAN
LAST YEAR.
DRONES DROPPED VARIOUS AREAS
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND FOUR
MILITARY PLANES WERE DAMAGED AT
AN AIRPORT IN WESTERN RUSSIA.
WE ARE OF COURSE FOLLOWING ALL
OF THIS ON THE GROUND FOR YOU.
AS CNN'S MELISSA BELL IS LIVE IN
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, WHAT ARE
THE KEY TAKE A WAYS AS WE REPORT
THIS NEWS, MELISSA?
>> CLEARLY THAT THERE WAS THIS
HUGE NIGHT OF MISSILE STRIKES
AND DRONE STRIKES, AS YOU SAID,
THE BIGGEST HERE IN UKRAINE
SINCE THE SPRING IS SIGNIFICANT,
OF COURSE BECAUSE OF THE DEATHS,
THE DAMAGE IN KYIV.
AND YOU SHOWED THOSE IMAGES,
REALLY IMPRESSIVE IMAGES OF
KYIV'S NIGHT SKY, SOMETHING WE
HADN'T SEEN IN AWHILE.
STILL I THINK THE IMPORTANT
THING TO TAKE AWAY FROM IT IS
HOW EFFECTIVE UKRAINE'S AIR
DEFENSES WERE.
THERE WERE 28 MISSILES LAUNCHED
AND 16 DRONES, ALL BUT ONE OF
THE DRONES WERE INTERCEPTED AND
I THINK THAT IS SIGNIFICANT IN
SHOWING HOW WELL THEY ARE
FUNCTIONING.
AND PERHAPS THE MOST INTERESTING
THING OF WHAT HAPPENED OVERNIGHT
WAS THE DRONE ATTACKS ON RUSSIAN
SOIL.
AS YOU SAID THE BIGGEST ONE
SINCE THE START OF THE WAR AND
EXTREMELY FAR FROM UKRAINE'S
BORDERS.
INCLUDING THAT SUCCESSFUL ATTACK
ON THE AIRFIELD UP IN THE VERY
WEST, NORTHWEST OF THE COUNTRY,
MUCH CLOSER TO THE ES TON YAL
BORDER THAN THE UKRAINIAN.
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE OF THE
TARGET AS FAR AS THE WAY-- AS
FAR AWAY FROM UKRAINE AS IT IS
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE DAMAGE
DONE.
RUSSIA'S AIR DEFENSES DID MANAGE
TO STOP SOME OF THOSE DRONE
ATTACKS.
SIX REGIONS IN ALL WERE TARGETED
BUT THE ONES THAT DID GET
THROUGH MANAGED TO DAMAGES
TRANSPORTER PLANES THAT WERE
PARKED AT THAT AIRPORT IN
SCOTLAND.
THE POINT IS THAT THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF PLANES THAT ARE USED TO
TRANSPORT TROOP, EQUIPMENT, TO
TRY AND BRING REINFORCEMENTS TO
RUSSIAN TROOPS HERE IN UKRAINE.
SO A VERY SPECIFIC TARGET IN
TIRMS OF ITS DISTANCE AND IN
TERMS OF THE NATURE OF WHAT WAS
STRUCK.
THIS GOES TO THE HEART OF
UKRAINE'S STRATEGY.
KYIV DOESN'T COMMENT ON THESE
INDIVIDUAL DRONE ATTACKS ON
RUSSIAN SOIL BUT IT HAS IN THE
PAST ELUDED TO ITS STRATEGY AND
DID SO AGAIN TODAY THROUGH THE
VOICE OF A PRESIDENTIAL ADVISORY
WHO SPOKE OF THE FACT THAT THE
WAR WAS MOVING TO RUSSIAN SOIL
IT IS ABOUT BRINGING IT TO THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE AS IT HAD BEEN
BROUGHT TO THE UKRAINIAN BUT
ALSO OF COURSE ABOUT TRYING TO
TARGET KEE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
RUSSIA THAT MIGHT BE HELPED AS
PART OF RUSSIA'S ATTEMPT TO PUSH
BACK UKRAINE'S COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
I THINK IT IS SIGNIFICANT THAT
THESE DRONE ATTACKS SOME MANAGED
TO GET THROUGH SUCCESSFULLY AND
A BLOW TO MOSCOW.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM RUSSIA'S
FOREIGN MINISTRY IS THAT THESE
ATTACKS WILL NOT GO UNPUNISHED.
THIS WILL HAVE RATTLED MOSCOW,
SOME OF THE DRONES THAT WERE
INTERCEPTED WERE HEADING TO
MOSCOW, AGAIN BECKY THRKSZ IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF KYIV'S
STRATEGY AND IT IS INTERESTING
THAT IT IS DOING IT AS
SUCCESSFULLY AS IT SEEMS TO BE
DOING IT FOR NOW, BECK